presenter: Good afternoon everyone.
[laughs]
Thank you all for coming out
this afternoon.
We're honored to be hosting today's guests.
This has been a work in progress
for a few weeks and today's guests,
as you all know, is Jad and Robert,
hosts of Radiolab.
And--
[applause] [laughs]
And a very special guest,
the Avant Cellist, Zoë Keating.
[applause]
So, as this room is proof positive,
Radiohead-hah. Radiohead.
Radiolab is well known
around the Google campus
for its unique and thought-provoking
mix of modern-
I'm sorry-
thought provoking mix of human curiosity
and cutting edge sound design,
covering scientific and cultural topics
from often very unique angles.
And those of you that have heard their
podcasts know exactly what I'm talking about.
And Zoë, she's known
as a one woman orchestra.
She fuses classical cello sounds
with modern technology
to produce incredibly rich and
dynamic array of music pieces.
No two performances of Zoë's are alike
and today will definitely be no exception.
Jad, Robert, and Zoë are
currently on tour together,
performing a live version
of Radiolab entitled "Symmetry".
And on behalf of the @Google team,
it's my pleasure to introduce you
to Radiolab and Zoë Keating.
[applause]
Robert Krulwich: So we were enjoying
the extensively huge Green Room,
which includes a pool.
You probably don't, cause you probably
don't come to this building often.
There's a golf course over there.
It's enormous.
It's very plush.
Jad Abumrad: Are you ready?
Yeah. Hey, everyone.
Robert Krulwich: I'm Robert
and this is--
Jad Abumrad: Jad.
Robert Krulwich: Jad.
And this is Zoë.
And we understand that you,
we didn't know what to call you --
Googlielols or whatever.
However, we got advice
from a variety of people.
You are Googlers.
You are Carpooglers.
You are Geegooglers, Nooglers, Zooglers,
and maybe, like if we do this right,
they'll be Zoëooglers and Jadooglers.
Jad Abumrad: We should be so lucky.
Robert Krulwich: Yeah, so you wanna, I guess
the first question is what's unusual about us?
[Jad laughs]
Jad Abumrad: Well, I figure
since we're here with Zoë,
honored to be here with Zoë
and thank you all for the invitation.
We're so happy to be here.
We thought we would do something
which sketches the sort of,
if Zoë and Radiolab overlap,
what's that portion of the Venn
diagram that we all share?
So, I'll get things started.
Then we'll throw to Zoë.
Radiolab, as you may know,
is a show about all kinds of things.
It's about ideas.
It's about questions.
It's sometimes about science.
It's about storytelling.
But if you put the content aside,
it is, I hope, a show that
when you turn on the radio,
or hit play on your iPhone
or Android phone, it will-
it just sounds different.
It hits your ears in a different sort of way.
So I wanted to start there
and just to talk a little bit about
what it is that we think about
when we're making the show
and we're making the sounds in the show.
I think the reason that Radiolab sounds
the way it does has to do with how we,
how we bleed borders.
And I'll tell you what I mean.
A while ago,
when we were first working on the show,
I ran into an essay by a guy
named Walter Murch.
I don't know if any of
ya'll know Walter Murch.
He's a great film editor.
He edited 'The Godfather'.
He edited 'Apocalypse Now'
and a ton of other movies.
And he wrote this essay,
which started with a very simple diagram
where it was one line and
then it had on one side "words",
and on the other, "music".
So we're gonna basically,
in our low rent way,
do that for you now.
So --
[laughter]
Robert Krulwich: I'm sorry for you
in the middle back area.
You can't, but this is gonna
be for you a true radio experience.
I know like in row seven,
you can't see anything.
[laughter]
Jad Abumrad: We are radio.
Robert Krulwich: This'll be all you'll see.
Jad Abumrad: We are radio, after all.
We don't do pictures very often.
Robert Krulwich: Yeah, we don't believe
that you should see anything.
Jad Abumrad: So, you've got
these two poles of sound.
You've got "music" on one pole
and "words" on the other.
And the idea is pretty simple initially,
which is that a word is,
it's an agreement of a kind.
So, like this thing right here.
[knocks on table twice]
This table.
The only reason we call this thing a
"table" is because sometime long ago,
some people got together and
agreed that the syllables, ta-ble,
mean this.
But then, in the Mediterranean--
Robert Krulwich: It probably wasn't
a discreet meeting, but never mind.
Jad Abumrad: No, it wasn't that exactly.
But the point is that the meetings
happen differently in different places.
In Arabic, we call it "tawila".
That's somehow what we call this thing.
In the Philippines, they call it "mesa".
So in other words,
it's completely arbitrary.
It's just a collection of syllables that you,
in a sense, have to crack the husk
of in order to extract the meaning,
which is nothing more than
a picture of a table.
So that's a word.
It is an agreed upon thing.
Now, music requires no agreement.
It is a,
for instance,
if I play for you--
Robert Krulwich: Well,--
Jad Abumrad: Hold on, hold on.
If I play for you this, right here,--
♪ [classical music plays]
Now would you say this
means sadness?
Does it represent sadness?
It just is sad.
There's something about,
this is "Adagio for Strings" and I'm
sorry to do this for you, to you,
'cause it's the most manipulative thing ever.
But it just embodies sadness.
It's the kind of sound
that has no intrinsic meaning.
It just repre--
it is the thing that it is.
It's an emotion embodied.
So in a sense, t
he difference, as you, would you
like to register a statement?
Robert Krulwich: Well, I just, as a footnote,
if you were living in the center
of the Brazilian jungle
and had no sense of this kind of music,
you might hear it and think
it was joyous, or I don't know.
Jad Abumrad: No, that's absolutely true,
but you wouldn't--
Robert Krulwich: I don't know. You might not.
I don't know.
Jad Abumrad: Well, I mean
what's the big debate,
actually as to whether music
has a universal meaning.
But my point is simply that
it is not a linguistic meaning.
It is a, somehow,
an embodied meaning.
So what you've got are on the one pole, words,
which is an encoded sound.
It's a code that you have to crack.
And then here, you've got an embodied sound.
And that's how the schematic
that Walter Murch laid out.
Now, I think Radiolab works, when it does,
sonically, because we confuse the two.
So I'm gonna play you a little three-minute
thing that some of you may recognize.
And then we'll deconstruct.
This is the opening to a show;
one of the first shows that Robert
and I worked on together.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] And let's begin
today with something deceptively familiar.
Robert Krulwich: [on audio clip] Fireflies are
something that we have all loved as kids, right?
Catching them in the backyard,
putting them in a jar
and watching them glow.
So we don't tend to think of them
as anything all that mysterious.
Well, they do one thing very nicely,
which is flash on and off.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] That's all
fireflies do, flash.
But what interests Steve Strogatz,
a mathematician at Cornell University,
is that there are places in the world--
Robert Krulwich: [on audio clip] Not here, but
in Southeast Asia, in Malaysia or Thailand--
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] Where fireflies
don't just flash randomly, like we're used to.
They somehow flash together.
Man on audio clip #1: There are enormous
congregations of fireflies along riverbanks.
Man on audio clip #2: How many?
Robert Krulwich: [on audio clip] It could
be tens of thousands.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] Tens of thousands.
Robert Krulwich: [on audio clip] Tree after tree,
extending for literally miles along the rivers,
all flashing in sync like a Christmas tree.
Rows and rows of Christmas trees
all wired together, going off.
And it's one of the most hypnotic and
spellbinding spectacles in nature.
Because you have to keep in mind,
it is absolutely silent.
Picture it, there's a riverbank in Thailand
in the remote part of the jungle.
You're in a canoe,
slipping down the river.
There's no sound of anything,
maybe the occasional exotic
jungle bird or something.
And you're looking and you just see--
[vroop, vroop vroop]
with thousands of lights on and then off;
all in sync.
[electronic music]
[water lapping]
Man on Audio Clip #2: Imagine all the trees
as far as you can see,
brilliantly lit and then totally dark.
Brilliantly lit, total darkness.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] All of them in sync.
Man on Audio Clip #2: Yeah. And no
Westerner had ever seen this sight.
There was folklore.
There were stories about it,
but nobody had gone in and
photographed and captured samples.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] Well,
not until 1965.
Robert Krulwich: [on audio clip] This was done
by John Buck.
Man on Audio Clip #3: John Buck.
B-U-C-K.
Man on Audio Clip #1: One of the great
researchers.
Man on Audio Clip #3: According to
the records, I'm 92.
Man on Audio Clip #1: Buck and his wife,
Elisabeth.
Woman on Audio Clip: Elisabeth Mast Buck.
Man on Audio Clip #1: Went to Thailand
and captured bags full of male fireflies.
Woman on Audio Clip: You could just reach up
and shake the branches
and fireflies would rain down.
Man on Audio Clip #1: And brought them
back to their hotel room.
Woman on Audio Clip: And we turned off
the lights.
Man on Audio Clip #3: We turned them loose.
Man on Audio Clip #1: And saw that the fireflies
flittered around on the walls and ceiling.
Man on Audio Clip #3: They flew
back and forth.
Woman on Audio Clip: Flashing randomly.
Man on Audio Clip #3: Elisabeth lay
on the floor of the room.
Woman on Audio Clip: I was just tired and John
stayed awake and he was the one who saw.
Man on Audio Clip #1: Within a few minutes,
little groups, duos and trios, formed.
Man on Audio Clip #3: And after a while.
Man on Audio Clip #1: A fourth one
would join in.
Man on Audio Clip #3: They got
closer and closer together
and then finally,
they were synchronized.
Man on Audio Clip #1: The whole room
was blinking in perfect harmony.
Woman on Audio Clip: He was excited the next
morning when he told me about it. [laughs]
[Man on Audio Clip #3 [laughs]
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] Twenty years later,
John Buck is still asking this question.
Man on Audio Clip #3: Well, what is going on?
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] Because no one knows.
Man on Audio Clip #1: There are
literally ten theories.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] What seems
to be clear, says Steve,
is there is no one firefly
that makes it all happen.
It just happens on its own.
Order materializes out of nothing.
[end clip]
Jad Abumrad: I'll stop it right there.
So, that was how we opened up a show,
which ultimately was on the idea of
groupthink and how does groupthink--
I'm just gonna fix this,
the microphone, real fast.
How does groupthink come out of individuals
who are like myself at this very moment,
not so smart?
[audience laughter]
There we go.
That's better.
So we go and talk about
all kinds of things.
But I wanted to zero in to,
for just a moment,
on the visual picture of the fireflies
as they're flashing on and off.
Now, there's a case where you have,
you've got music.
You wanna put up your music?
You got your music.
[audio clip starts]
Man on Audio Clip #1: And let's begin today.
Jad Abumrad: So here's the music.
[music]
Jad Abumrad: It's giving you feeling.
It's embodying a feeling,
but you've also got the words.
Man on Audio Clip #1: It's one of the most
hypnotic and spellbinding spectacles in nature,
because you have to keep in mind,
it is absolutely silent.
Picture it.
There's a riverbank--
Jad Abumrad: So, we've got words
and music on either end.
But you've also got this thing that happens
about ten seconds into the scene.
[bird sounds]
The bird.
The sound of a bird.
So, where does that fit in?
Well--
Robert Krulwich: Well, Strogatz said,
"There's the occasional sound
of the bird."
Jad Abumrad: Exactly, and you hear--
[bird sounds]
So, it's kind of like a word.
Robert Krulwich: What if he said
there's the occasional sound of a tricycle?
Would you have a--
would you have had a tricycle?
Jad Abumrad: If it made sense
to have a tricycle, sure.
So, you've got now a slightly,
it's not exactly words.
And it's certainly not music.
But it's something like a word
so it's a linguistic sound.
So, let's just take this little bird.
Can we affix it to, say,
your elbow here?
[audience laughter]
Robert Krulwich: My elbow,
because it's closer to--
Jad Abumrad: It's closer to "words", right?
So you've got that.
But then you get to a certain point
where you've got the words.
You've got Steve.
You've got the music.
You've got a bird.
You've got the sound of
water at a certain point.
But then you also have fireflies.
And I remember as we were
making this, we're like,
"What do fireflies sound like?
They don't actually make sound."
Robert Krulwich: Remember also, Strogatz said
that this whole event takes place in total silence.
Jad Abumrad: That's right.
Robert Krulwich: So we're violating
some rule that he set up.
Jad Abumrad: Absolutely.
Oh. You're about to lose your bird.
Robert Krulwich: I am going to lose my bird.
Jad Abumrad: Well, but,
OK it's on your hip now.
Well, alright, well.
The bird is on his elbow
in our imagination.
So, fireflies was an interesting thing.
I think fireflies, for me,
captures something about what
we try and do on the show always.
They don't make sound,
but you want to evoke it in sound.
But there's no sound effect
for a firefly, thank God.
So, after much trial and error,
here's the sounds we came up with.
[bird sounds]
That's the bird.
[electronic beep]
Just that.
No firefly in the history of
creation ever made that noise.
But somehow it creates for
you an impression of a firefly.
Now, what would you,
where would you put this?
Well this, I think,
I would put it probably
[audience laughter]
--there.
It's smack in the middle.
It's evoking something like the image
that you would get from a word,
but it's not doing it literally.
It's a musical gesture that somehow
creates the impression.
And for me, this moment
and some subsequent
moments were kind of an epiphany.
I was like, "If we can do that,
if we can get right between them,
you can create a sonic space that is
precise in the way that you need it to be",
which is what a sound effect will give you,
but it won't date the way
that a sound effect does.
It won't sound canned the way
Anything I say over this music
sounds poignant.
It's amazing.
[audience laughter]
[audience clapping]
But.
Robert Krulwich: Out of curiosity, the three
elements of the sound of the fireflies.
It seemed like
there were three parts.
Do you go to a--
where do you, where did,
what trunk of sounds do you look at?
Jad Abumrad: That's a, that's a,
it's a little bit of the music
and then I made the beep
a third above it.
So it's just a little tiny stack.
And then this,
I cannot remember
how I made that noise.
Robert Krulwich: Well, these sounds
are all software developed.
You take the sound that
you find on a record,
or in a file somewhere,
and you screw it up.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah.
Yes, sometimes you steal it.
Most of the time you screw it up.
You filter it so you get these little high
squeals or something that in some way--
Robert Krulwich: I wouldn't say
you steal it in public.
I would say what you do is you made it
so different from what it was
that it became an original act.
That's the [inaudible] you were looking for.
[audience laughter]
Jad Abumrad: That's, yes.
Thank you for legalistically putting me
in the right place.
But so, for me, that talks about, that's,
for me, the key of Radiola
So that firefly,
right there on your breastbone
is where we try and live.
Robert Krulwich: So, Zoë, your music is also,
as we're about to hear
is a pile up of sounds also.
Zoë Keating: Mm-hmm.
Robert Krulwich: Your sounds come
from this instrument.
ZoÎ Keating: This.
Robert Krulwich: Can you explain
what else you got?
ZoÎ Keating: Well, so I've got this cello.
His name is Ariej
and he's from France.
He's very sensitive.
But I--
Robert Krulwich: Is Ariej a girl name
or a boy name?
Zoë Keating: He's a boy.
Robert Krulwich: Boy.
Zoë Keating: Yeah. And so, I play Ariej
and I record the sounds
in real time into the computer
and I use a bunch
of midi controls to do that.
And then, I just play these layers
of sound back at the audience
and then I play on top of them so that you have
little pieces that make up a whole larger piece.
Robert Krulwich: And like Jad is
trying to evoke something specific,
but he's trying to invent a vocabulary,
as he puts it, in the middle
to find that specificity.
When you compose, do you compose to
pictures in your head, or moods, or what?
Zoë Keating: It's very hard to say.
I would call it an emotional landscape
that is made of emotion and light
and color and direction.
It's sort of this, it's like a feeling
and I imagine it
as a three-dimensional space.
Robert Krulwich: You do?
Zoë Keating: Yeah, definitely.
And when I record the sounds
and I place them in the sonic spectrum
for the audience, or on a CD,
it's very much like I'm crafting a shape;
these little, little shapes that make larger
shapes that make larger shapes, larger shape.
And they have some kind
of meaning to me
that is absolutely impossible
to express in words,
which is why I can only
do it with music.
Robert Krulwich: But you know
you're in the right place
when the shape is present in your mind,
or is it like filling a container
to get to a shape?
Do you arrive early, or do
you arrive along the way?
Zoë Keating: [laughs] Can you
rephrase that question?
[audience laughter]
Zoë Keating: By a shape,
I mean like for example a little,
it might be some sort of translucent,
semi-translucent, you know.
Robert Krulwich: Oh, don't even
try to describe it.
Just play something.
Zoë Keating: Well, I think I'm gonna play,
since that music was so nice,
I think I'm gonna play a piece
called "Sun Will Set".
And now, I have a real hard
time naming pieces
because I don't like to
put meaning on them.
And one thing I love about this piece
in particular is I wrote it a while ago.
And I get emails all the time
from people
who tell me what it means to them
and what it is and their meaning
and they're totally certain about it.
Robert Krulwich: And you think they're
totally right. Wrong?
Zoë Keating: Well, the thing is that it means
whatever it means you at that moment
and that's a completely valid
interpretation.
So it might have meant something
when I wrote it.
And then it meant something
when I mixed it that was really different.
It means something different.
It's different every time
I play it on stage.
It has a different meaning.
Robert Krulwich: So now,
for the very first time ever,
is a composition that you have
already played many times before.
Zoë Keating: Yes.
[laughter]
Robert Krulwich: Oh, just go ahead.
[Zoë Keating plays cello]
[applause]
Jad Abumrad: Wow. Zoë, can I ask you
a question about that song?
Since we were talking about the ways
in which music can or cannot
evoke meaning, or pictures,
or that kind of thing,
you call that song Sun Will Set, right?
I was just thinking,
musically, actually in a way,
the sun doesn't need to set cause your loops
can always just keep going in a way.
Zoë Keating: There you go.
Jad Abumrad: You know?
Zoë Keating: Well, I was sort of,
I mean, "Sun Will Set".
Out here in California we enjoy
these really long sunsets and so,
those ones that never end and they go on
and on and on and on and on and on.
Robert Krulwich: I was curious if you had [sings bit
of music that Zoë played] if in the first iteration,
you had made a mistake,
you'd be stuck with the mistake, right?
Your foot is, then what do you do?
Zoë Keating: That happens all the time.
Robert Krulwich: Oh it does?
Zoë Keating: Yeah.
[audience laughter]
Robert Krulwich: So then are you--
Zoë Keating: That's how I write new music.
[audience laughter and applause]
Actually, a surprising amount of
my music comes from mistakes.
Jad Abumrad: In what sense?
Zoë Keating: Well, in the, I'm recording
something and I might do it wrong.
And then you have to save the piece
by playing the rest of the loops
to go along with the thing you did wrong.
And then that might, or might not,
lead to something interesting.
So.
Robert Krulwich: You've been
interested in loops, right?
Jad Abumrad: Yeah.
Actually there was a moment for me
actually when the idea of looping
was really, became very, very interesting.
I'd love to play,
if you guys are OK with it,
a three minute piece.
If you're thinking back
to the words and music,
a dichotomy that you had up,
there was a moment
where I realized that--
it was sort of a Zoë moment really--
where I realized that words
could become music instantly.
This is a short, short introduction
to another show,
which just makes that point.
It doesn't need much setup,
so I'll just play it.
Diana Deutsch: I'll tell you what happened
is that when you do post-production,
as you know--
Jad Abumrad: I should just say that
woman speaking is Diana Deustch.
She's a music psychologist.
And this is describing a realization
that she had that we,
that we used in our story.
Diana Deutsch: I'll tell you what happened
is that when you do post-production,
as you know, of speech, you loop things,
loop things, loop things
so that you can zero in on piece.
Pu-pu that sound too loud.
You need to unpop, or s's that
sound too sharp and so on.
So you put things on loops in order to
fine tune the way the speech sounds.
So I had this particular phrase
on a loop and forgot about it.
Jad Abumrad: What phrase was this?
Diana Deutsch: It's a phrase that occurs
at the beginning of the CD in which I say,
"The sounds as they appear
to you are not only different
from those that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so strangely
as to seem quite impossible."
Diana Deutsch: [simultaneously] as to
seem quite impossible.
Diana Deutsch: Now, I had "sometimes
behave so strangely" looped.
Diana Deutsch: [simultaneously] The sounds
as they appear to you
are not only different from those
that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so strangely,
sometimes behave so strangely.
Diana Deutsch: Just those few words.
Diana Deutsch: [simultaneously] Sometimes
behave so strangely.
Diana Deutsch: And forgot about it.
Diana Deutsch: [simultaneously] Sometimes
behave so strangely.
Diana Deutsch: Sometimes behave so
strangely.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] So,
here's what happened.
Diana leaves her studio.
She closes the door and goes
into the kitchen to make some tea.
All the while, this loop is worrying
away in the background.
As she's sipping her tea, she thinks,
"Is someone singing?
Who's singing?"
Diana Deutsch: I heard what sounded
like song in the background.
Jad Abumrad: She realizes,
"Wait a second.
That's not singing, that's me talking."
Diana Deutsch: That very phrase.
Diana Deutsch: [on audio clip] Sometimes
behave so strangely.
Diana Deutsch: But at this point,
Diana Deutsch: [on audio clip] Sometimes
behave so strangely.
Diana Deutsch: it appeared to be sung
rather than spoken.
Diana Deutsch: [on audio clip] Sometimes
behave so strangely.
This is "sometimes behave
so strangely" right? [laughs]
You still hear the words,
but they're sung words
rather than spoken words.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] It's weird.
Like it just switches at a certain point,
three or four repetitions in.
Diana Deutsch: Right.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] It's going,
it's going, and then pow.
It becomes music.
And then now none of us
can get it out of our head.
Like, the whole office is like,
♪ sometimes behave so strangely. ♪
Jad Abumrad and Diana Deutsch:
♪ Sometimes behave so strangely. ♪
Diana Deutsch: And you know what?
If you do this demo and then you
go back to the original sentence,
it sounds like speech to begin with and
when you come to that very phrase,
I seem to be bursting into song.
Diana Deutsch: [on audio clip] The sounds
as they appear to you
are not only different from those
that are really present,
but they sometimes behave so strangely
as to seem quite impossible.
I have to say this can continue
for months and months.
It's sort of like your brain gets altered
for that particular phrase
and it continues to sound like singing
[Voices Singing]
♪ Sometimes behave so strangely. ♪
Diana Deutsch: --for a very, very long time.
[Voices Singing]
♪ Sometimes behave so strangely. ♪.
Jad Abumrad: [on audio clip] All right.
So here we have just one small indication
that music is, well,
it behaves very strangely.
Jad Abumrad: I'll just drop it out there.
But it's one of those things
where it makes you realize like,
if a word repeated can become music,
then what the hell is music really?
You know?
Robert Krulwich: Do you, do you,
do you --
when you hear your own phrases that
you have invented for certain pieces,
do they sometimes seem fresh to you?
Sometimes stale to you?
Because things are going round and round.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, one of the tricks of being a performer
is to try to make your pieces new every day,
if you're performing day after day.
And I know that I am --
things are going well if I can play
a little phrase and I don't get bored.
But often, it's such a subtle difference.
It's like, it's some really subtle thing
that happens at the end of the bar
that makes it interesting for five minutes
or interesting for ten seconds. [laughs]
Robert Krulwich: And when it's at ten second,
when you're having an OCD moment
with the phrase, can you bury it?
I mean, it's in this machine.
Can you say, with your foot,
"Go away now?"
Zoë Keating: Yes, yes I can.
Robert Krulwich: OK.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, yeah I can.
Robert Krulwich: Yet there is something about
what both of you do that you both
play with time in an interesting way.
For you, something is made and then goes
around and round and round and builds.
And it seems like you are always
thinking about more, less, stop, go.
It's interesting.
Why do you guys like each other?
[audience laughter]
Jad Abumrad: Yeah. She's nice.
Robert Krulwich: I'm making
a presumption about --
Jad Abumrad: I'll speak about
what I find fascinating.
I think Zoë's music is amazing.
So there's--
Zoë Keating: And I think Radiolab
is amazing.
Jad Abumrad: It's not an entirely
rational thing.
But I like imagining that when you're
playing there's first just one Zoë
and then suddenly there are two Zoë's,
and then there are four Zoë's,
and then there are eight.
And suddenly there's an entire, entire quantum
orchestra that is created in the moment.
And the Toscanini is your left foot there.
Zoë Keating: But that is
kind of true in a way.
I spent most of my teenage years
playing in orchestras
and it was like a peak experience
for me, was to play in an orchestra.
And then it did dawn on me recently that I might
have recreated the cello section for myself.
[Robert Krulwich laughs]
Digitally.
Robert Krulwich: Can you do one --
before we get to questions and answers,
is there anything else you'd like to,
just to, you and your foot?
Zoë Keating: Do my foot?
Robert Krulwich: To play, I mean.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, I could play.
Robert Krulwich: And your hand.
I shouldn't really demote your hand.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, I'll play another piece.
Robert Krulwich: It's just the foot
that's so interesting.
Zoë Keating: This one has some starting
and stopping in it, which you might like.
Robert Krulwich: OK.
[Zoë plays cello]
[applause]
Zoë Keating: Thank you.
My socks are very slippery.
Robert Krulwich: Your socks are slippery.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, I usually
don't play in socks.
I have special performance shoes
that have toes that are pointy
and rubber and very elegant shoes.
And I didn't bring them.
So I have to do socks.
Robert Krulwich: Where do you shop
for cello-foot, cello-feet shoes?
Zoë Keating: It's not something
you can look for on Zappos.
It's not one of the categories.
[laughter]
Robert Krulwich: So, what is it,
the original intended use for the shoe
that you use was jogging?
Zoë Keating: [laughs] I think
just looking nice.
Robert Krulwich: Looking nice.
Robert Krulwich: OK.
Question time.
The only
rule I was told was that apparently
if you can't get to a microphone then
you just shout it out and I'll repeat it.
If you can, which is there's one here,
and then let's do that.
[pause]
male #1: Hi, thank you.
Robert Krulwich: Let's see,
you have to turn on the mic, there.
male #1: Check, one, two.
Robert Krulwich: There you go.
male #1: Hi, thank you for coming.
Love the show.
For me, the third dimension
from words and music,
if I had to stretch it out, would be imagery.
And I found it was hard for me
in Zoë's first song
to block out that imagery
that came with that song.
I believe it was on TED XSF,
her website, correct?
Zoë Keating: Ah. I didn't know that.
male #1: So, I had a hard time--
Robert Krulwich: Oh, this is
hardcore fandom here.
Zoë Keating: I didn't know
that that was on the website.
Robert Krulwich: The shoe salesman with her
who sold her the thing will be along shortly, I think.
male #1: But the subsequent
song is much easier to not have preacquired
image in my mind.
Zoë Keating: It's like when you hear
something in commercials.
male #1: They were city shots of
the San Francisco Bay area and the bridges.
Zoë Keating: Hmm. Well, I'm gonna
have to see this.
male #1: So I was curious,
I saw also that you played mostly
with your eyes closed
and it helped me with the latest song,
just to close my eyes.
Very different watching you versus
just having my eyes closed.
So, does that help you in forming that three
dimensional shape that you had in mind?
Zoë Keating: Yeah. I'm a very
deliberate eye-closer.
I close my eyes for two reasons.
One is that I don't know if you know,
but when I close my eyes, I'm invisible.
[audience laughter]
And so, and it really helps me perform
when I know that I'm invisible.
And the second reason
is that it just helps me--
Robert Krulwich: It's alarming to the rest of us.
Zoë Keating: Yeah, yeah it is.
But you can, just the cello remains.
But, and the other reason is that that landscape
of sound that I was talking about that,
it's like I can see it when I close my eyes.
And if I open my eyes, I see you
and it makes it very hard.
There's this kind of disconnect
between what I'm seeing and
what I'm creating with the music.
So, if I close my eyes, then it's all,
it's right there.
Jad Abumrad: Are they all
with you in that place?
Or is it by yourself?
Zoë Keating: The landscapes?
No. I'm definitely not alone
by any means.
Robert Krulwich: I close my eyes
when we were, actually.
Do you close yours?
Jad Abumrad: You do close your eyes.
'Cause often, I'm gesticulating like-Robert?
Robert Krulwich: [laughs] I do.
I do it.
I don't know why.
I wanna be by myself in tandem but --
[audience laughter]
Jad Abumrad: Together, but alone.
male #1: Thank you.
male #2: I close my eyes when I'm listening to ,
well, when I'm not driving.
And anyway, thanks for the show.
It's amazing how you bring science
and sound effects and everything.
It's so compelling in a way.
So, one thing that, and the show
definitely sounds different
from anything else
on the radio or anywhere.
One thing I know that you do every show,
that you get people who appeared
on the show to read the credits.
So I'm just wondering.
Do you just really play back everything
they recorded on your answering machine,
or you edit it out in some way?
Jad Abumrad: What do you mean?
Do we use their voices, you mean like
all the fumbles and mispronunciations?
male #2: I know it's--
Robert Krulwich: Thank you, Jad A-bim-rad.
Did I get that right.
Jad Abumrad: Like, part of the whole,
part of the whole thing for us is just,
'cause we're two idiots who are wandering
through the world trying to figure things out.
And somewhere along the way,
we started doing this whole credits thing
because the credits, credits are
like one of these puzzles and--
Robert Krulwich: We're not allowed to say them.
It's a legal thing.
Apparently the people at NYC decided that hosts
of any editorial product should not advertise.
So then the choice to say,
"Money brought to you by blah blah
blah blah," was not available to us.
Jad Abumrad: And it's also,
I mean it's just generally,
like, it's tune out time
when there's the credits.
So we're like, "How can make it not a tune
out moment and make it a fun moment?"
And so, we had people start reading
the credits and they instantly pronounced,
mispronounced my name 400 times.
Every time, we're like,
"Is, is kind of funny."
[audience member laughs]
So it somehow reinforced
the notion of ourselves that we have,
which is that we're not gonna
take ourselves too seriously.
Robert Krulwich: There's also,
I think--
male #2: Your name, the name
of the foundation that funds you.
Jad Abumrad: Well, we try and keep those
from not being pronounced.
They have less of a sense
of humor about it than I do.
Robert Krulwich: I think there's another
sort of a richer thought here
that all journalism is a package
and when it's done on ABC or NBC,
you know the package very well.
And when it's done on NPR you know
the package very well, actually.
So we decided to make that
a little bit more transparent.
So we have people whose headphones
fall off in the middle of interviews
and they have to find them on the floor.
We always keep that stuff.
[audience laughter]
Jad Abumrad: It's true.
male #2: [laughs] Thank you very much.
Jad Abumrad: Sure, thank you.
male #3: Hi, my name is Mark.
And Zoë, I just wanted to say first
that your music is extraordinary.
It's really beautiful.
Zoë Keating: Thank you.
male #3: So thank you.
Jad Abumrad: Mark, I would like to say
that your t-shirt is extraordinary.
Robert Krulwich: Extraordinary.
[audience laughter]
Zoë Keating: Yeah, I love that t-shirt.
male #3: I'm surprised I'm not seeing more.
Go to chopshop.com, or whatever it is.
They're great.
So for Jad and Robert, I think Google and
Radiolab share a mission in some sense.
That is, organizing information
and making it accessible.
There's some things I think Google
does better than you,
but there are a lot of things that they --
Robert Krulwich: Like what?
[audience laughter]
male #3: Scale.
Robert Krulwich: Just asking.
Robert Krulwich: Scale.
male #3: Scale and different languages.
Robert Krulwich: That's fair.
Jad Abumrad: Revenue might
be another one too.
[audience laughter]
male #3: So, but there's some things that
I think that you do a lot better than us.
For one thing, I think making stories
and information sticky,
I know you did a show on that.
But also you make it consumable
in a way that I don't have to,
I can do other things while
I'm consuming the information.
I can drive.
I can work out.
I can do things like that.
So my question for you is this.
In Google Search in particular,
I think we're stuck on the "words"
end of that spectrum.
So how would you fix Google Search?
[audience laughter]
Robert Krulwich: How much [audience laughter]
should we charge for this answer?
Jad Abumrad: Yeah.
male #4: Sounds like an interview.
male #3: You can think about it
and do a show on it.
Jad Abumrad: How to fix Google Search.
Does Google still have like
"I just wanna like get lucky" option?
[audience laughter]
male #3: In many ways, yes.
Jad Abumrad: I think that came out of
my mouth wrong, but you know what I mean.
Robert Krulwich: Well, I mean one of the things
that Google doesn't do very much of is--
we do leave the written word
and the literal words behind
and we do play with the sounds a lot.
And so, the business
of searching for an answer.
You're right.
A lot of journalism is done
where a reporter goes,
decides on a question
that they wanna solve.
And then goes and reads a book
and interviews people
and takes notes and gets it down.
And then, in a voice
as authoritative as they can,
trying to sound omniscient,
they say,
[speaks deep, nonsense syllables],
this sort of sound.
And our plan right from the beginning
was to say "we don't know".
We begin by stumbling around.
And you see, people use Google to stumble,
but we are actually trying to
try to figure something out.
What's very interesting for us is,
because we wanted people to hear
what it's like to ask stupid questions,
what it's like to argue
in the middle of an investigation,
what's it like to interpret data.
We had a huge fight about
falling cats the other month.
We wanted to let people know
that there is no,
that it's not a binary business that you
don't know.
Beep. You know.
That there's a middle.
And the middle is where most people live
and the middle is where most
people are afraid to go.
If you don't think you're gonna
understand something,
you try to wait for someone else
to solve it for you.
What our secret advertisement
is is you can, too. Like, look at us.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah, it's funny.
It's to applying that to
the Search question.
Given that there is no bright shining line
between knowledge and ignorance,
that the hierarchy of the search
results sometimes is misleading.
And there's such a premium placed
on being first or second or third,
or on that first page.
And there's something about the format
which sort of creates an expectation
of relevance that somehow,
maybe if you could confound
that in some way,
but still keep it ordered.
So there's some sort of presentational thing
that maybe it could represent the information
in a different way and different dimension.
Robert Krulwich: Yeah, cause I always think
when you're looking for an answer,
sometimes as in a library,
you get caught in the middle of
your search by some other idea.
And then you just turn around and
suddenly you're doing something else.
And the fun, and the surprise,
of looking for one thing and finding
another is missing in a very teleological,
very directed search.
In Googleland,
"So you want to know X.
We'll move step by step by step
inevitably towards X."
Whereas we say,
"You want to know X.
Well that's nice.
And then, you know."
[audience laughter]
And you forget why you came here.
In Google, you don't ever forget.
I mean, actually that's not fair.
Jad Abumrad: I'm not sure that makes
a terrible amount of business sense
to give people what they don't want,
but we'll get back to you on that.
male #3: Well good.
Jad Abumrad: We'll send you a bill, too.
male #3: All right, I look forward to the amounts.
Thank you very much.
Robert Krulwich: Thank you.
male #4: So, a while ago, I don't know
if you're still doing this or not,
you could send a text to a number
to donate ten dollars to WNYC.
And I thought that was a really great idea.
And so, one thing I wanted
to encourage you.
So this is my question, which is
really a thinly disguised request,
is could you encourage WNYC
to allow people to donate easily?
'Cause when I tried, every time
I hear the radio, I'm like,
"I really want to support these guys."
So I go to WNYC and
I start filling out the form.
And then I get to the second page
and I'm still filling out a form.
And then I get to the third page and I'm like,
"I don't want to tell you
how much my median income is.
I just want to give you money.
Take the money, please."
[audience laughter]
So, yes.
I would love if you would encourage
the encouragement of the program.
Robert Krulwich: We are in a peculiar situation
where we have a large number of listeners
who are very much in that mood
and we are terrible business people.
[audience laughter]
And we haven't quite figured out
how to pluck coins from their pockets
because, I think, we also get lost.
I think we're so busy making the thing
that we forgot to pay for the thing in a way.
And so, we do have to get back.
We do have a lot of homework
to do in that area.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah. But the business
model is basically what you just,
you are the business model, basically.
I like you.
I would like to support you.
So, yeah, you're right.
The mechanism of that is sometimes
clumsy and we're working on it.
But it's all about just people in a sense,
giving you money from their heart in a way.
And--
Robert Krulwich: Like you know,
she's making a pile at heart.
Jad Abumrad: We have, we have
a lot to learn from her. [laughter]
Robert Krulwich: She is. Like, how much
do you charge on iTunes for your songs?
Zoë Keating: Well, iTunes is flat.
It's 99 cents per song.
Robert Krulwich: 99 cents per song.
Zoë Keating: But on Bandcamp, I have
a minimum of eight dollars for an album.
Robert Krulwich: Minimum of eight dollars?
Zoë Keating: Yeah.
Robert Krulwich: What's your average receipt?
Jad Abumrad: Can they give you
more than eight if they want to?
Zoë Keating: Yeah, they can
give me anything they want.
And so, some people will give me
a hundred dollars or fifty dollars.
But the average is $12.
Robert Krulwich: So the average
is well above what's required?
Zoë Keating: Mm-hmm.
Robert Krulwich: So is that a kiss?
Zoë Keating: It's definitely a kiss.
Robert Krulwich: It's a kiss.
Zoë Keating: Yeah.
Robert Krulwich: So there's a big,
fat kiss out there.
And all you have to do is
just get your lips next to it.
It's like --
she's closer than we are.
[audience laughter]
But that's, that's a business model,
is to pucker, somehow.
[laughter]
male #5: And I heard one slightly e-mistake
earlier on, of mentioning Radiohead.
Actually got me thinking of,
well, there's actually Radiohead uses
some of the same techniques
you use in sound editing.
And I'm wondering,
are they an inspiration to you?
Is it something that
you try to strive towards, or--
Robert Krulwich: We're suing them.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah.
[audience laughter]
male #5: Will you tour with
them soon?
Jad Abumrad: Well, you know Radiohead.
Those guys are inspired by the same
people that we're inspired by, sonically.
I mean, that's a rock band that
pulls in avant classical influences.
It pulls in electronic influences.
It's not concerned with genre borders.
And I think we're the same way.
I mean, the fun of it just on the craft level
and also just in this chatty level is to,
is to disrespect borders.
So an interview becomes
a weird bit of Radio Theater,
which then becomes a strange
sonic landscape,
which then just becomes
a conversation again.
Like, those very distinct borders that
you hear in other shows
are the very things we try
and destroy just for fun.
And I think Radiohead has
the same approach to, to music.
I'm not inspired by them specifically,
although I like them, personally.
male #5: Thank you very much.
Robert Krulwich: I have some, here, also,
I guess these come from somewhere,
but go ahead.
I, I will--
female #1: Are you sure?
Robert Krulwich: Yes. Go ahead.
female #1: This is for Zoë.
I actually grew up playing cello.
And so, I love what you do
for multiple reasons.
I mean, obviously, I'm at Google.
So I'm a huge technerd.
So I love what you do with that.
I also, I personally never enjoyed
playing in symphony very much,
so I love that you get to do what you want
and really bring out the cello music,
because, of course,
it's the best instrument.
But--
[audience laughter]
Yes. Yes.
Big cello geeks.
Anyway.
My question for you actually--
Robert Krulwich: You're gonna be killed
by a violist one say.
[audience laughter]
female #1: Yeah, that might happen.
Yep, that might.
My question for you is when you're not
writing your own music,
how do you hone your craft?
Is there certain classical music
that you still learn and practice?
How do you hone your craft?
Zoë Keating: Yeah, actually,
I do practice classical music
because there's nothing quite
like it for improving your technique.
Because I can get really lazy
if I just do what I want.
It's like I just go to the fridge
and I keep eating the pickles.
Left to my own devices.
So, occasionally, I go--
Robert Krulwich: There's a metaphor for you.
Zoë Keating: and I practice,
I really like to work through,
I have all these books
of orchestral excerpts,
which is the cello parts
for various symphonies.
I like to play that 'cause it's really good.
Symphonic music is all about blending,
and so I work hard to blend.
And then I also spend
a lot of time improvising.
Like, it's really important not just on my own,
but when I can with other people,
because just to sort of broaden your horizons.
And then, just allow myself
to make mistakes
cause I have a tendency to make things more
and more and more and more and more perfect,
until they're dead.
And it's important to add that
element of chaos back in.
female #1: OK, thank you.
Zoë Keating: Yeah.
Robert Krulwich: Before we go on to the next
question, though, you should stand by.
This comes from Kate Bee.
This must be from the diaspora of Google,
like Google Other Campus.
No?
Where is this from?
Where are these people?
presenter: From the Radiolab on Facebook.
Robert Krulwich: Radiolab's Facebook page.
Our own people. OK.
But are they part of this?
Are they looking at us?
Oh, OK. Hello, Kate Bee.
That's her name, Kate B-E-E, as in the insect,
which is a nice thing.
If you could collaborate
with anyone living,
artists, scientists, writer, anyone,
who would it be and
what would the project be?
Jad and you.
Jad Abumrad: And what
was the question again?
If I could collaborate with anyone living?
Robert Krulwich: You could
collaborate with anyone living.
He could be, she could be a scientist,
a writer, a DJ, artist, anyone.
Who would you like to collaborate with?
Jad Abumrad: Zoë, you go first.
Zoë Keating: No. I was hoping
you would go first so I can think.
Jad Abumrad: Well, OK, here's my--
roundabout way of answering that question.
So, recently, I've been really
fascinated with-- what?
You and I have already
collaborating on things.
This is an aspirational question.
This is not for someone who's not---
Robert Krulwich: I didn't want to be left out.
Jad Abumrad: Okay.
Robert Krulwich.
Robert Krulwich: Thank you.
Anybody else?
Jad Abumrad: Well, yes.
Recently, I've been really fascinated by
this guy Joshua Davis, who does visual art.
And he works with computers.
And he programs these computers
to have, like to make pictures for him.
He'll give the computer certain rules
having to do with shapes and how the shapes
intersect and which colors go together.
And he just hits the space bar
and the computer just barfs out
thousands of pictures.
And some of them are ugly and
some of them are amazingly beautiful.
And he then, acts as a kind of curator.
And he like, "Oh, no, no, no, no, oh,
that looks nice, no, no, no, no, that's nice."
And he then basically, he's the curator
of his machines artistic output.
And there's something kind
of cool about that for me.
There's something very "of this moment"
that the machines have become
so brilliantly capable,
but artistically dumb.
They don't know what's pretty.
They don't know what's good,
but they can make things that are
much better than us at this point.
So, I don't know.
Maybe I'd collaborate with
Joshua Davis's machines.
[audience laughter]
Zoë Keating: That's a good answer.
I know that-
I know who I want to collaborate with,
but I don't know who they are yet.
If that answers the question.
Robert Krulwich: So, if that's a shape
in your head, what kind of a shape is it?
Zoë Keating: What I really wanna do
is I wanna collaborate with someone
to try to render this landscape
in a visual way.
Like, as I'm playing it on stage.
And just sort of experiment
with that in projections
and a new graphical environment on stage.
Jad Abumrad: But you've don't that
before in some way, right?
Zoë Keating: I've done it
in small bits but never fully,
like, somebody who's really involved in going
all out to try to figure it out as a problem.
So I'm actually looking
for that person.
Jad Abumrad: Google.
Robert Krulwich: Maybe you're that person,
who can, -- who are you?
male #6: My name is Hunter.
Hello.
Robert Krulwich: Hi, Hunter.
male #6: Very small graphics ability.
Actually, I had a question for Zoë.
The new album is awesome.
"Don't Worry" is what I wake up
to every morning.
Zoë: Thanks.
male #6: But I was wondering.
So you do a lot of like, textual, with everything
being laid on top of each other.
And I was wondering, are you thinking about
doing anything like with a soundscape?
Like with stereo.
Have things kind of at different points so
you can hear different parts and pull it out?
Zoë Keating: You mean, more like doing things
like just, with less instruments, or--
male #6: No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
like instead of just stereo,
just having like 5.1 or some sort
of three-dimensional soundscape.
Zoë Keating: Oh, yeah.
Oh, of course.
I'm always, I'm always for more,
bigger, better, more. [laughs]
More dimensions, yeah.
That's, I actually, somebody, I have
a recording I'm gonna work on next,
which would be the idea is to do it as
hi res as possible with surround sound.
male #6: Oh, cool.
Very cool.
Have you considered ever releasing
any songs as multitracks
so other people could play around with it?
Zoë Keating: Yes. Yes. People ask all the time
and I have a database of loops,
because every time I have a performance,
the loops are there.
I save them.
And so, since I used to be
an information architect,
I thought I should just make
some way to categorize them all
and then people could pick and, pick
and choose from the database of loops.
Jad Abumrad: It would be cool
if from the moment you performed,
somehow there's some backend thing
just throwing them into the internet.
Zoë Keating: Could be. Somebody
might find that useful.
Jad Abumrad: Somebody here I bet
could do that in like, five minutes.
[audience laughter]
Robert Krulwich: You have some
work questions. I'm good.
Before you go,
this is from Jeff Seamster.
He wants to know what are
your three favorite sounds.
Zoë Keating: I love trains.
Robert Krulwich: Trains.
Trains.
That's one.
While you're thinking of the other two,
Jad, three favorite sounds.
Jad Abumrad: The hum of the refrigerator.
Robert Krulwich: You're making this up.
Jad Abumrad: Well, I don't know.
I'm not sure it's my favorite.
But it's on the list somewhere.
Zoë Keating: My son's giggle.
Robert Krulwich: Yeah, we like that.
Jad Abumrad: I see that one, too.
Robert Krulwich: OK, while you're thinking,
you ask something.
[audience laughter]
male #7: So, Robert, earlier you asked
how Zoë and Jad are alike.
And it occurred to me, especially listening
to their answers to the questions,
that one of the really interesting ways
is how you play with the intersection
between craftsmanship and serendipity
in the things that you produce.
And I guess that's one the things
that is while,
makes Radiolab sound so interesting
and so different to me,
is how, and Zoë, your music as well,
whereas a classical piece is very
well crafted and very well honed.
And while a normal radio piece
is often very scripted
and has that authoritative voice
that you mentioned.
Radiolab is much more conversational,
has much more serendipity thrown in.
And so I guess my question
is about your process.
How you balance the two.
Do you just get a bunch of stuff together?
Do you get a bunch of music together?
And then you hone it, hone it, hone it
and that's what you produce?
Or, do you have to go
back and forth sometimes?
How does that,
how does that work?
Robert Krulwich: Our method is completely,
completely ridiculous by almost any measure.
It's conceived as an anti Ira Glass, I think.
[audience laughter]
'Cause we very much admire him,
but we couldn't bear to be like him.
We just wanna be like,
as good but different.
And that's actually hard.
He's so good in so many places.
So we decided just stupidly that one of
the things that he does a lot is he reads.
Everybody on that show reads
from the script.
So we decided arbitrarily.
We're not reading.
That led to the most bizarre production
system ever invented by anyone.
Jad Abumrad: Yes.
You see what will happen is like;
one of us will make a thing.
We'll come in with our thing
and it's really like, it's made.
It's like, indelible and perfect
and like she was saying, dead.
Right?
And then, we'll put it there and
then we'll start yakking at it
and we'll throw all the yak in and then
it gets really long and loose and flabby.
And then we're like,
"It's long and loose and flabby."
So we cut it back,
cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut,
and it's kind of beautiful again,
but it's not totally dead but it's sort of dead.
So we're like, "OK."
So then we yak at it again,
da-da-da-da-da-da,
put that back in and
it's a little less flabby,
but then it needs to get cut back.
And there's tension.
Robert Krulwich: What this means,
by the way,
in real life is that we are
actually going into the studio
and have sound that goes, "blahblahblahblahblahblah,"
and then I go,
"wawawawawaawwawawa".
We put it all together and
then that sounded good.
And then we do the whole thing over again
because we didn't like it.
And then we take it and some of the previous
one and we do that over again.
And then it gets down to wheedly things,
'cause of the musician in him will say like,
"That should be the answer."
"Well, I just said that."
He says, "No. You said that
should be the answer.
THAT should be the answer,"
and it gets like that.
It gets really ridiculous--
Jad Abumrad: It doesn't really
get like that, Robert.
I mean, honestly,
let's just think about it.
Do we ever talk, "That?"
No, it's all just like vomited out
and it gets edited into being.
It is actually, on some level, improvised;
almost everything in the show.
Robert Krulwich: That's true.
So, yes.
And it's musical, really.
The logic of it is musical.
And that's, that's the difference, I guess.
I think other journalism outfits just try to
be authoritative and right and on time.
And ours has to be beautiful in some
way that exists right between us.
And we don't have the same
sense of beauty all the time,
except in the very, very last,
last iteration, we kinda do.
It would be as if you were making,
you had a vase and he had
an iris and daisy and a tulip.
And I had an iris and a daisy and a tulip,
and you can put them in in any,
you can snip them and over.
And the thing is you have to agree at a certain
point that that's a beautiful arrangement.
And it's so delicate and so weird and
so hard to get and then when you get it,
we seem to agree.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah. And it is, and I think you
actually, in your question, captured it really.
It is, in some sense,
about a kind of like gladiatorial dual
between the part of you that likes to organize
and the part of you that wants anarchy.
And then the two of them
have to fight to a draw,
I feel like for Radiolab to
get a special, special groove.
Robert Krulwich: OK, let's, thank you.
One more and then maybe a Zoë
and then we'll waltz out of here.
male #8: Hi.
Thanks again for coming.
I'm Dan.
So currently, public radio is
under attach in a lot of ways.
And Radiolab is a show
that often engages in big,
philosophical questions that often
have political implications about
humanness and life and all that stuff.
And I was just wondering if you guys
have come under any scrutiny
or had been criticized at all
from listeners or people
within the larger public radio world?
And if so, how do you
deal with that?
How do you respond?
Jad Abumrad: We've been criticized,
not in the way that public radio
has been criticized now,
but we get criticized
for using too many sounds.
We get criticized sometimes by,
very rarely actually,
by scientists who feel like
we're being too poetic,
or we're using too many metaphors.
We get criticized by people who don't
wanna hear so many layers.
They just wanna hear someone
talking in a plain, simple way.
We get those kinds of,
those criticisms constantly.
Not the other kind.
Thank you.
Robert Krulwich: I don't know
how we've been exempt from,
I mean, we don't have a right-wing
kind of cabal that's saying,
"We know the real reason
why you chose looping for your show.
It's part of the--
"No, we don't. I don't know how
we've avoided those people.
Yeah, socialist looping.
We haven't had that.
[audience laughter]
male #8: Can I ask a quick follow-up question?
Robert Krulwich: Yeah.
male #8: Robert, I heard a rumor
that you have an impression
of conservative talk radio.
Is that true?
[audience laughter and clapping]
Robert Krulwich: No, I don't.
male #8: Do you have
an impression of NPR?
Robert Krulwich: I like,
I mean, frankly some of the people who do
conservative talk radio arevery talented.
They can be very funny.
Jad Abumrad: Rush Limbaugh actually is,
have you ever listened to him in the morning?
It's amazingly produced.
I mean--
Robert Krulwich: I don't do
impressions of him, though.
Jad Abumrad: Yeah.
Robert Krulwich: Yeah. I actually had
problems because I was, at one point,
suspended from NPR because I take,
I have a Zelig problem.
So, I can listen,
if I listen to something intensely,
or go to a place where everybody's
talking in a certain way,
I inadvertently talk like them.
So I was suspended once for
going to the Texas State Fair at NPR
and becoming a Texan inadvertently.
I didn't hear that I was one.
[audience laughter]
And that happened again
when I was interviewing the President of
the United States’ National Security Advisor.
He was Polish.
Zbigniew Brzezinski was his name.
And the interview started,
and I said, "How are doing?"
He said,
"I'm Zbigniew Brzezinski."
And I think in the middle, I was already,
I was, [speaking in heavy Polish accent]
"So you have a cold?"
[audience laughter]
And that was very bad.
So that's why I try to avoid impressions
whenever possible.
But thank you very much for not avoiding us,
like so many of you.
Jad Abumrad: Yes, thank you very much.
Robert Krulwich: So let's hear one more
from Zoë and then we'll say goodbye.
Do you have anything you wanna?
Zoë Keating: Well, if you guys can
bear to hear "Optimist" again.
Robert Krulwich: We can.
Jad Abumrad: Always.
Zoë Keating: OK.
Jad Abumrad: Please.
Zoë Keating: I dropped my bow.
Robert Krulwich: Optimists
never drop their bow.
You have to change the song now.
Jad Abumrad: It's a cool story,
I mean, this song for you.
It came from a cool place.
Do you just wanna set it up real fast?
Zoë Keating: Yeah, It's a song
that I wrote for my son, Alex,
who's ten months old and I wrote it
when he was negative four months.
So, yeah.
I hope he likes it.
Robert Krulwich: So he's into this tune
in all kinds of ways.
[Zoë laughs]
[Zoë plays cello]
[audience applause]
Zoë Keating: Thank you.
[applause]
Jad Abumrad: Sure. Again, thanks
so much for having us.
We had a great time.
It's really cool and inspiring to be here
and we'll be hanging out.
Robert Krulwich: Thanks.
[audience applause]
01:12:17.600,00:00:00.000